excelentísimo señor presidente de la
cámara de diputados
excelentísima señora
presidenta del supremo
he querido compañero vicepresidente de
la República alquim
señores jefes de estado de gobierno que
asistieron
señor primer secretario de la
señor procurador general de la república
Augusto aras
mi querida mi querida compañera
mi querido compañero
mi querida compañera Dilma Rousseff
expresidenta de la república
[Aplausos]
señores parlamentarios
señoras y señores jefes de delegaciones
extranjeras amigos y amigas
por la por tercera vez
comparezco ante este Congreso Nacional
para agradecer al pueblo brasileño el
voto de confianza que recibí el nuevo
juramento de fidelidad con la
Constitución de la República junto con
el vicepresidente gerald
es una prueba de lo que vamos a trabajar
estamos aquí hoy Gracias a la
consciencia política de la sociedad
brasileña y al frente democrático que
formamos a lo largo de esta histórica
campaña electoral fue la democracia la
gran victoriosa en esta elección
superando la mayor movilización de
recursos públicos y privados
las más violentas amenazas a las
libertades del pueblo
a la campaña de mentira y de odio
tramada para manipular
el pueblo electoral brasileño nunca
los procesos electorales fueron tan
desvirtuados y autoritarios nunca la
máquina pública fue tan desencaminada de
los procesos republicanos nunca los
electores fueron tan restringidos por el
poder y por las mentiras
diseminadas a escala Industrial a pesar
de todo la decisión de las urnas
prevaleció
gracias a un sistema electoral
internacionalmente reconocido por su
eficacia
fue fundamental
la actitud y el coraje del poder
judicial especialmente el Tribunal
Superior electoral
[Aplausos]
para hacer prevalecer la verdad de las
urnas sobre la violencia
de sus detractores señoras y señores
al volver a este plan alto a la cámara
de los diputados
participé de la asamblea Constituyente
de 1978
todo lo que planeamos aquí
democráticamente para inscribir en la
Constitución con el conjunto de derechos
sociales individuales y colectivos
En beneficio de la población y la
libertad nacional 20 años atrás cuando
fui electo presidente por primera vez al
lado del compañero vicepresidente
inició un discurso
sobre cambios cambios que queríamos para
explicar los preceptos constitucionales
por una como una vida digna sin hambre
con acceso a empleo a la salud y a la
educación
dicen
que la visión de mi vida estaría la
misión de mi vida estaría cumplida
cuando
cada brasileño y brasileña pudiera hacer
tres comidas por día
tengo que repetir este compromiso el día
de hoy quiero que se acabe la miseria y
la y el hambre
es este es un gran síntoma de la
devastación del país
hoy nuestro mensaje para Brasil es de
esperanza
el gran edificio de derechos y de
soberanía
que levantamos a partir de 1978
ha sido sistemáticamente demolido en
estos últimos años
este edificio de derechos nacionales que
vamos a dirigir con todos nuestros
esfuerzos ahora queridos amigos y amigas
en 2002
decíamos que la esperanza él tenía que
ser En este gobierno para superar los
temores
de un representante
de la clase trabajadora para representar
al país
después de los ocho años de gobierno
dejamos Claro que nos preocupaban los
ciudadanos si no no estaríamos aquí de
nuevo
se demostró que un representante de la
clase trabajadora podía ser
podía dialogar con la sociedad para
promover el crecimiento económico y de
forma sustentable y En beneficio de
todos especialmente de los más
necesitados se demostró que era posible
gobernar este país
con la más ancha participación social
Incluyendo a los trabajadores y a los
más pobres
en las decisiones del gobierno
[Aplausos]
a lo largo de esta campaña
electoral
vi la Esperanza a brillar en los ojos de
un pueblo
en detrimento de la destrucción de las
políticas públicas
para promover las políticas públicas y
sociales
ofrecemos esta oportunidad a sus hijos y
hijas esta oportunidad activa de que la
solidaridad sea más fuerte que el
individualismo es un gobierno de
transición
Un gobierno
qué piensa utilizar el recurso de la
salud
que desmontó la educación la cultura
y la protección del medio ambiente
la vacunación la seguridad pública
la protección de los bosques y la
asistencia social
y primaron la gobernanza de la economía
de las empresas de los emprendedores y
del comercio externo
de los bancos públicos entregaron el
patrimonio Nacional los recursos del
país fueron robados para saciar la
estupidez
de algunos pocos y de
mecanismos privados en detrimento de las
empresas públicas
junto al pueblo brasileño construimos un
país y haremos un país de todos y para
todos Yo quería decir a los diputados y
senadores que el resultado de nuestra
transición que fue coordinada
será enviada a cada diputado a cada
senador a cada ministro de la suprema
corte a cada ministro del tribunal
superior electoral a cada ministro del
poder judicial
a cada central sindical para que las
personas sepan Cómo es que nosotros nos
encontramos a este país y que cada uno
tome sus propias opiniones y decisiones
delante de este desastre
presentamos al congreso nacional
propuestas que nos permitan apoyar a la
inmensa masa de la población que
necesita ser apoyada Quiero agradecer a
la cámara nacional por la sensibilidad
con el pueblo brasileño
la actitud extremamente responsable
del supremo
frente a situaciones
que enfrentaban a los poderes
hice así
no sería justo
pedir paciencia para los que tienen
hambre
ninguna nación
puede subsistir sobre la miseria de su
pueblo los intereses de la población
enaltecimiento de la democracia
serán los Pilares de nuestro gobierno
este compromiso empieza por la garantía
de un programa de bolsa familiar
renovada más fuerte y más justo para
atender a quien más lo necesita nuestras
primeras acciones son rescatar del
hambre a 33 millones de personas y
rescatar de la pobreza a más de 100
millones de brasileños y brasileñas
de destrucción nacional que hoy se acaba
señoras y señores
este proceso electoral
fue marcado por el contraste
nuestra
centrada en la solidaridad y la
participación política y social para la
definición democrática la otra del
individualismo de la negación de la
política de la destrucción del estado
en nombre de la supuesta libertades
individuales
la libertad que siempre defendemos es la
dignidad con pleno derecho de expresión
y manifestación y sobre todo de
organización la libertad
la libertad que ellos dicen es de
oprimir al vulnerable
masacrar al oponente y imponer a la ley
de los más fuertes sobre la civilización
Y eso para mí es barbarie
comprendí
desde el inicio de la jornada
que debería ser candidato por un frente
más amplio que en el campo en el que me
formé y mantengo ese compromiso
este frente se consolidó para impedir el
retorno del autoritarismo en el país a
partir de hoy
la ley de acceso a la información va a
volver a cumplirse el portal de
transparencia volverá
a cumplir su patrón
los valores republicanos volverán a ser
respetados por el interés público
no tenemos ningún ánimo de revancha
contra los que intentaron destruir la
nación
pero vamos a garantizar el Imperio de la
ley
con derecho
de defensa y a través de un proceso
legal apropiado
el mandato que recibimos
frente a adversarios inspirados será
defendido con los poderes que nos
confiere la Constitución el odio
responderemos con amor a la mentira con
la verdad al terror y la violencia
responderemos con
con las más duras consecuencias
sobre la democratización
Hoy después del Terrible desafío que
superamos
decimos democracia para siempre
para confirmar estas palabras
debemos reconstruir la democracia en
nuestro país la democracia será
defendida por el pueblo para garantizar
a todos y a todos los derechos que están
escritos en la Constitución señoras y
señores
hoy hoy mismo
estoy poniendo medidas para reorganizar
la estructura del poder ejecutivo para
el funcionamiento del Gobierno Federal
republicano y democrático
para rescatar el papel de las
instituciones del estado
y las empresas estatales para el
desarrollo del país para las inversiones
públicas para el crecimiento económico
sustentable ambientalmente y socialmente
en diálogo con 27 gobernadores
vamos a retomar obras
y responsablemente paralizadas
que contribuyen el atraso del país vamos
a estructurar
un nuevo paquete para generar empleos
buscaremos financiamiento
nacional e internacional para invertir
para dinamizar y
expandir el mercado interno de consumo
de exportaciones de servicios y
agricultura los bancos públicos
especialmente el bnds y la estructura
del crecimiento de innovación tienen un
papel fundamental en este nuevo ciclo al
mismo tiempo vamos a impulsar a las
pequeñas y medias empresas
a las mayores
generadoras de empleo
y a la economía creativa
la economía va a volver a girar
en torno a la voluntad popular vamos a
retomar la política
del aumento permanente el salario mínimo
y vamos a terminar con la vergonzosa
fila de desempleo
otra consecuencia de este tiempo de
destrucción
vamos a dialogar
de forma tripartita gobierno centrales
sindicales y empresariales sobre una
nueva una nueva legislación de trabajo
para
garantizar la libertad
y la fuerza Social es un gran desafío en
los tiempos de hoy señoras y señores
Brasil
es muy grande para renunciar a ser una
potencia productiva
no es solo tema de importar combustibles
plataformas de pletóleo y procesadores
aeronaves estatales tenemos capacidad
técnica capital de mercado
para
retomar la industrialización
a nivel competitivo Brasil puede y debe
estar en la primera línea de la economía
global
la transición digital y la industria
brasileña
con la política industrial de innovación
y para estimular la cooperación público
Privada de ciencia y tecnología
y garantizar los financiamientos
conjuntos adecuados
el futuro
pertenecerá
a aquellos que invertimos en nuestro
conocimiento
planeada con el sector productivo con
las universidades
junto con los ministerios de ciencia
tecnología y e Innovación
la agencia de fomento
ningún otro país tiene las condiciones
de Brasil para volverse en una
convertirse en una gran potencial
con emprendimientos basados en la
biodiversidad vamos a ir hacia una
transición energética y ecológica para
el plano agropecuario
una estructura más fuerte
nuestra meta
es alcanzar las deforestación a cero en
la amazonía
y en materia energética
además de estimular
el aprovechamiento de pastos deshuesados
Brasil no piensa
eliminar ni destruir para fomentar una
industria
es solo
replantar los 7 millones de hectáreas de
tierra degradada
quemada
para invadir nuestros biomas
incentivaremos sí la prosperidad en la
tierra libertad de oportunidad para
crear
pero continuar haciendo Nuestro objetivo
no puede ser una tierra sin ley no vamos
a tolerar la violencia ni la
deforestación ni la degradación del
medio ambiente en nuestro país
Esta es una de las razones no la única
por la creación de los pueblos indígenas
Nadie conoce mejor nuestras nuestros
bosques
ni se ha encargado defenderlas tanto
a través de los tiempos inmemorables
cada tierra demarcada en una nueva área
de protección ambiental para los
brasileños y las brasileñas debemos
respetar
tenemos una deuda histórica
[Aplausos]
vamos a enfocar todas vamos a intentar
erradicar todas las injusticias contra
los pueblos indígenas
una nación
no se mide solo por las estadísticas
aunque sean súper impresionantes así
como un ser humano
una nación
se expresa por el alma de su pueblo
el alma de nuestra gente
y en nuestras culturas
estamos Armando el Ministerio de cultura
con la intención de tener más incentivos
culturales
una política cultural democrática
que brotes de todas las flores y se han
recogidos todos los frutos de nuestra
diversidad
sin censura y sin discriminación
[Aplausos]
no es admisible que negros y mulatos
continúen siendo la mayoría pobre del
país
que se ha construido con la sangre y el
sudor de sus antepasados africanos
para ampliar la política de las
universidades y el servicio público
además de retomar
las políticas enfocadas este tipo de
población que se fomente la cultura y la
educación para ellos
es inadmisible que las mujeres reciban
menos que los hombres
que no sean reconocidas en un mundo
político machistas que sean asediadas
impunemente en el trabajo que sean
Víctimas de violencias constantemente
estamos refundando también el Ministerio
de las mujeres
para combatir la desigualdad
[Aplausos]
no Existirá una verdadera justicia en el
país
Si un solo ser humano es
el Ministerio de los Derechos Humanos
estará ahí para que Cada ciudadano
Tenga sus derechos fundamentales
respetados
en la protección
delante de las autoridades públicas la
ciudadanía
es otro nombre para nuestra querida
democracia
el Ministerio de la justicia y la
seguridad pública
se asegurará de separar los poderes y
promover
la igualdad de las comunidades pobres
combate combatir el crimen organizado
las milicias y la violencia
este Dónde esté
estamos
reformando los decretos sobre Crimen y
la seguridad pública
que tanta inseguridad
han tenido que aguantar las familias
brasileñas Brasil no quiere
armas para el pueblo quieres seguridad y
educación y cultura para que la gente
pueda ser un país más justo
sobre la protección de Dios
inauguró este mandato afirmando que en
Brasil la fe puede estar presente en
todas sus formas
Iglesias y cultos en este país todos
podrán podrán ejercer
su religiosidad señoras y señores
el pedido
fue marcado por una de las mayores
tragedias de la historia la pandemia de
Kobe 19 en ningún otro país la cantidad
de Vidas perdidas fue tan alta en
relación a la población en los países
más preparados
para las emergencias sanitarias gracias
a la competencia de nuestro sistema
único de salud
y de la vacunación
esta paradoja
está paradojas solo se explica por la
actitud criminal de un gobierno
negacionista
obscuro e insensible hacia la vida
la responsabilidad por este genocidio
tienen que ser no tienen que quedar
impunes
[Aplausos]
lo que tenemos en ese momento
es dar solidaridad a los familiares
hermanos padres
y casi 700.000 Víctimas de la pandemia
es probablemente
la parte democrática de la Constitución
ciertamente por eso
fue la parte más perjudicada por por
esta parte que debería ser revocada
vamos a recomponer la salud para tener
asistencia básica la farmacia popular
el acceso a la medicina especializada
vamos a recomponer la educación invertir
más en universidades en enseñanza
técnica
la universalización del acceso a
internet
la enseñanza pública
Esta es la inversión
que llevará el desarrollo del país el
modelo que proponemos aprobado en las
urnas exige compromiso y responsabilidad
credibilidad y previsibilidad
pero estuvo hecha a partir de realismo
fiscal
controlando la inflación y respetando
a los que gobernamos este país y para
los que gobernamos
tenemos la obligación de hacer
mejor de lo que hicimos en el pasado
señoras y señores
a los ojos del mundo
Brasil ha estado en los ojos del mundo
en esas elecciones
la crisis climática y un ejemplo de país
social ambientalmente responsable capaz
de promover el crecimiento económico
combatir el hambre
a través de un proceso democrático
nuestro protagonismo
retomará la cooperación latinoamericana
a partir del mercosur
la gobernanza soberana de nuestra región
podremos reconstruir
un diálogo
con Estados Unidos la comunidad europea
china los países de Oriente y otros
actores globales fortaleciendo los brics
y rompiendo con el aislamiento al que
este país ha sido sometido en estos
últimos años
Brasil
tiene que ser dueño de sí mismo dueño de
su destino tiene que volver a ser un
país soberano Somos responsables
por la mayor parte del mundo la amazonía
acuíferos
petróleo fuente de energía limpia con
soberanía y responsabilidad seremos
respetados para compartir esta grandeza
con nuestra comunidad solidariamente y
jamás con subordinación
la relevancia
de la elección de Brasil es ver por fin
otra vez el modelo democrático
enfrentando
[Música]
una oleada de extremismo autoritario
con odio y mentira
y sin ningún tipo de control
transparente defendemos la plena
libertad de expresión
creamos instancias democráticas para
garantizarla
de responsabilización
para combatir el odio y la mentira
Este es un desafío civilizatorio
y también para la superación de Las
Guerras y las crisis y el hambre y la
desigualdad en el planeta reafirmo
reafirmo para el Brasil y para el mundo
la convicción de que la política
en el más elevado sentido
en contra de las limitaciones
para el diálogo entre intereses
divergentes
para tener un consenso Pacífico negar
la política
es camino de barbarie y de tiranía
mi más importante misión a partir de hoy
será honrar la confianza recibida Y
corresponder a las esperanzas del pueblo
de Brasil que jamás perdió su futuro ni
su capacidad para superar los desafíos
la fuerza del pueblo y la voluntad de
Dios tenemos que reconstruir este país
viva la democracia viva el pueblo
brasileño Muchas gracias